all right I think I'm on welcome lot to
talk about tonight different time
testing out different audience seeing
who's on at different times a day going
to talk about some really interesting
revelations that sort of prove to us
that not only is the entire Russia thing
not really about Trump but also that all
of Russia's actions have really been
perfectly believable in some sense and
I'll get into that in a little bit we'll
talk about the pending indictments I
know there's a bunch of questions
related to some of the stuff that's been
going on on the YouTube channel lately
so I'll address that as usual we now
have a number of different on-screen
gimmicks that might encourage you to
make contributions either via super chat
or at stream labs.com slash the david
pakman show number one is that
contributions will show up up here -
they will show up here see just donated
$1 and in addition there's this new
thing where the balls will drop in you
where is it into the cup which is kind
of a cool thing so anyway I don't know
if people really care about this stuff
but it does seem to get some people
excited at least you uh-oh I already
don't like where this is going has
tipped another dollar and is filling up
the cup see you hmm
I think we can all sort of tell where
this is going right in any case welcome
to the live stream thanks to Brian dang
who's who has made a $2.00 contribution
and his balls are falling into my sort
of like a Belgian style that's the type
of glass I drink a Belgian style beer
out of another dollar tip from C and
pretty good physics animation there I
kind of like that you know okay if this
is your first live stream with us yes
it's really live unless you're watching
a replay number two super chat is on you
can use super chat which is the dollar
sign at the bottom of the chat window to
send questions or comments those will be
read questions will be answered comments
will be responded to you can also now as
of a couple of streams ago
use stream labs.com slash the david
pakman show and then it's same thing you
can make a contribution and also send a
comment but it's circumvents youtube's
30 percent super chat fee so that's kind
of a cool thing new members and patrons
will get live shoutouts and thank-yous
during the stream if you become a member
or a patron those are the primary
sources of funding for the program I
will thank you profusely and sing your
praises last time I made up fake
compliments for people so more on that
in a few and please obvious trolling and
hate will get you banned I'm only a
minute in and shockingly one of our
moderators has already had to delete
people's messages and we I haven't even
done anything yet worth criticizing Jace
I don't get what is up with people and
yes we can talk just very briefly
hey Treon we're trying to raise money on
patreon we're really getting screwed on
YouTube we're not really making any
money on YouTube anymore and it used to
be like half of our funding so I always
try to paint a pretty picture put
rose-colored glasses on whenever I'm
talking about anything related to the
show but the truth is we're getting
crushed and we want to replace that
revenue and one way we're doing it is
through patreon we are at 1936 patrons
my challenge to you today during this
live stream is let's get to 1950 okay we
failed last time but I think we could do
it tonight let's get to 1950 patrons and
if we do I will create and release for
you a major major coupon code for
membership right now there's a 40%
discount code I voted 17 I promise that
if we get to 1950 patrons tonight I will
outdo the 40% discount code with
something that hopefully people will
like maybe they won't but I'm hoping
that they will alright so let's get into
what's going on with the rush of stuff
so there's been a lot of rush of related
news over the last week or so and I've
been making an effort because I I know
that there's so much other stuff than
Russia and I'm really making an effort
like the first six 15 or 16 minutes of
today's program was just me doing an
in-depth analysis of Donald Trump's
tax proposal right I like doing that I
think that there's value to doing that
but I can't indefinitely ignore the
Russia story because it is a real story
after all and we've learned a number of
different things number one we now have
a Democratic Senator Senator Richard
Blumenthal from Connecticut who says
that he believes there is a 99% chance
that both former national security
adviser Michael Flynn and former Trump
campaign manager Chairman Paul Manafort
who
the Trump campaign pretends was like an
intern that nobody really knew but
actually he was the chairman and at one
point the campaign manager for Donald
Trump that both of them are getting
indicted and if that happens it is going
to irreversibly turn the types of
discussions we hear about Trump Russia
we've already been seeing it happening
it's been going to there was no
collusion to the collusion wouldn't be
illegal to Trump had no idea about the
collusion it's going to be yet another
shift in that direction but that's not
really what I want to talk about what I
want to talk about is something that
we've learned about in the last 24 to 48
hours
and what that is is that Russia has
actually been involved in much more than
just the Donald Trump campaign and
initially when it was Trump wanted
Russia to win there were people who
reacted and said why would Trump want
Russia to win it doesn't really make
sense why would why would they like
Trump and from the beginning I've been
referencing thanks to the d2j bug who
donated five Canadian dollars we'll get
to your Super chat in a bit
I've been referencing a book called
foundations of geopolitics by Alexander
Dugan by the way it's looking like that
the the $5 contribution is so
significant that it knocks the other
coins out of my out of my beer glass
here where is it here it is there it is
I've been talking about foundations of
geopolitics for a long time and it's by
Alexander Dugan and you can google this
I mean this is this is widely available
you don't have to take my word for it
and in fact if you're a savvy or
critically thinking media consumer you
shouldn't take my word for it look it up
for yourself in foundations of
geopolitics Alexander Dugan outlines
that the strategy that Russia should
take with regard to the United States to
sort of prop themselves
of geopolitically is seed chaos any time
you offer an opportunity to support a
dissident group in the United States do
it anytime you have an opportunity to
fuel racial tensions particularly
involving African Americans do it and
what has happened with Russia over the
last no I guess you know more acutely 18
to 24 months but really it extends
beyond that is that that's exactly what
they've done so when we look at Russia's
involvement just with the Trump campaign
we say well why would they want Trump to
win and of course it's not because they
like Trump it's because a trump
presidency predictably and it happened
would jeopardize the credibility of the
United States around the world it would
throw the internal domestic politics of
the United States into chaos case in
point it's happened know Obamacare
repeal no Mexican wall that Mexico is
gonna pay for no restructuring of trade
deals so that it'll be great for
everybody we're now talking about the
tax plan but it's been eight months and
there's been nothing has happened right
that's really the goal of Russian
geopolitical strategy so now what we've
learned and if you haven't heard about
this I'll catch you up and we did a
story on the regular program today we've
learned a bunch of things about Russia's
involvement number one we found out that
Russia was buying at least some ads
promoting black lives matter gun rights
and the NRA geo-targeting them on
Facebook specifically to Facebook users
in Ferguson Missouri and Baltimore
Maryland sites of significant racial
unrest and violent protests over
treatment of african-american men by
police so you would say wait a second is
it again is it that Russia supports
black lives matter and the Second
Amendment no it is much more nuanced
than that it's that it is an opportunity
to further inflame tensions of all kinds
and again go to Alexander Duggan's
foundations of geopolitics now we knew
that yesterday right we've since learned
that in addition to that the internet
research agency
connected to a number of Twitter
accounts there's a Twitter account
called let me see if I can I think it's
banned now it's called either black to
vist or black to vist s' let's see I
believe it's black to vist s-- and it
has been suspended so the Twitter
account black to vist s' we now know was
actually being controlled by Russian
players and in particular it appears to
relate to the internet research agency
really good research is out there about
the internet research agency it's
basically a Russian internet trolling
firm and of course it's never totally
clear how officially connected they are
to the Kremlin or how directly involved
are knowledgeable Vladimir Putin is but
needless to say this is an establishment
Russian trolling firm and they were
involved in pumping up all sorts of
racial animus through Twitter
not creating topics out of thin air that
aren't relevant right police and the
relationship to african-american men
that's a real issue Russia didn't invent
that issue but really successful
Facebook and Twitter accounts controlled
by Russians meant to agitate and this
this is the strategy right so if you
want to argue well it's not clear that
it's to their advantage you can kind of
debate and argue that but what really
can't be denied just google it
foundations of geopolitics by Alexander
Dugan this is exactly what Alexander
Dugan prescribed Russia do with regard
to the United States 20 years ago it's
what they're doing it's there it's sort
of like when we say can we really
believe that Donald Trump might might
have made unwanted advances against I
don't know at this point what reporter
it was recently someone from MSNBC I
told you about it a couple weeks ago
well he only told us that he grabs him
by the [ __ ] whenever he wants and when
you're famous he can just kiss women
whenever he wants to doesn't matter what
they think blah blah blah blah blah you
just have to go back to what was said
before and here big coincidence what
Russia is doing coincides exactly with
the geopolitical playbook of Alexander
Dugan from
years ago and and please before emailing
me and telling me I don't know what I'm
talking about just look at it yourself
google it look at it yourself and and
and see what it is that's actually there
xx Jamaica thank you for the
contribution and thanks also to Brian
Rasmussen for the contribution
I wonder what determines whether the the
coins go in or whether they don't some
are bouncing around and some are going
in or knocking other I kind of like this
I have to tell you it's very
entertaining whoo there goes one popped
out and there it is yeah the physics of
the balls seem okay I would say no no
we'll keep it we'll keep it up for now
let me jump into a couple of the Super
chats here and then I will get to stream
Labs contribution messages so the DJ Jay
bug sends a message saying it's not easy
being green
alright couldn't couldn't really add
more to that xx Jamaica has sent a $5
super chat dave rubin said the left
thinks little white boys and girls are
evil in greg gutfeld interview part 2
your thoughts and why do you hate white
kids yeah I am I mean I just don't think
that's I don't think there's any
evidence that the left thinks little
white boys and girls are evil I think if
you want to establish that we would want
to establish that empirically alright so
by the left I certainly I I'm gonna sort
of employ charity here I assume Dave
Rubin is not implying that every
individual on the left thinks little
white boys and girls are evil so
presumably he means some significant
portion or maybe a majority or maybe a
plurality we would want him to define
that and then we want to cite some kind
of source we would want to cite a source
that indicates that a plurality a
majority or some portion of the left
hates or thinks little white boys and
girls are evil and of course
statistically most of the left is white
so it would be some pretty serious white
self-hatred xxxx Jamaica I know you
don't hate kids but that's what Dave
said yeah I know I understood it I got
it
hob bitten has sent a five British pound
super chat David don't you realize that
it's not the Russians it's the squirrels
the squirrels run everything yeah I
that's what I meant I think that's what
I meant and Katie rice Katie rice has
sent a dollar super chat with no
question or comment thanks very much I
do appreciate that and then now let's do
Stream Labs contributions of course you
can make contributions at stream labs
comm slash the David Pakman show they
will put your name up here they will
trigger an animation somewhere over here
and they will also drop some balls or
coins or whatever they are in this Cup
okay so stream labs comm slash the David
Pakman show first one is from Brian dang
who says the election board made the
gender error on Kushner's registration
okay so this is related to today's story
that Jared Kushner is registered to vote
as a woman and the elections board is
indicating that it is their error and
there's a link here that Brian sent the
New York State Board of Elections
acknowledged in a news report the
president Donald Trump's son-in-law and
senior adviser Jared Kushner registered
to vote as a male despite being listed
as a woman previously all right so
that's one form at least that it appears
Jared Kushner filled out correctly
Christina sent a dollar stream lab
donation when was the last time if ever
that you were stuck on the side of the
road because of car trouble
I got a flat tire on my way home it was
not nearly as fun as a David Pakman live
stream right now I can assume that
Christina um let me think when was the
last time I was stuck on the side of the
road because my car broke down you know
I I genuinely don't know I've been stuck
on the side of the road oh well you know
what actually no I do remember three or
four days after getting my last new
lease I was still living in New York
City sort of a snowy day and I was
driving from New York City up to Western
Massachusetts and I did not see because
of the snow a pothole on the New York
what highway was it I guess it would
have been at that point 87 North got a
flat tire totally threw my alignment out
of balance brand-new car right I'm three
days
into this new lease or something I end
up pulling over in the Bronx which I
know when I tell people they think it's
scary it was it was fine it really was
no big deal and I was able to just speak
Spanish with people and it was all fine
but because of the snow Triple A was
saying it's gonna be hours before we get
to you and my car's roadside a cistern
assistance was telling me it's gonna be
hours before we get to you so I said no
problem
I'll just get the tire change there's a
million tire shops in the Bronx and I
remembered that when I had got in the
car I was told listen you have one of
the five lug nuts on your wheels is
different and you need a lock nut in
order to open it to unto to loosen it in
order for people not to be able to as
easily steal your wheels and I said I
remember that pop the trunk it's not
there and it turns out that the
dealership had forgotten to give me the
lock nut and instead had mailed it to me
of course I was on the road so
ultimately I ended up making at home at
about 4:30 in the morning to Western
Massachusetts after fortunately my
girlfriend's dad purchased like at the
top level triple-a and with the top
level triple-a you can get one tow a
year of I think it's a hundred and
seventy-five miles which would have been
a $1,600 tow they flatbed towed my
vehicle I think they're 162 miles from
the Bronx to Northampton Massachusetts
of course the trucks have a speed limit
of like 50 so it took four and a half
hours instead of the normal three of
that I don't know it was absolute and
total nightmare so that was the last
time and it wasn't good it wasn't good
that folks I can tell you for sure
Brian Rasmussen has sent the dollar
stream lapse contribution do you suspect
Jill Stein has any remorse for her role
in electing Trump also how many times a
day are you mistaken for Jake Gyllenhaal
I get that online but but never in
person I don't know that Jill Stein has
remorse for her role in electing Donald
Trump what I do think is that there are
real questions about Jill Stein's
connection to
and because she never had a shot they
weren't really looked into like the
Trump campaigns connections to Russia
were but more and more is being written
about it and I think that there is I
would like to see it looked into that
that's what I'll say Pakman fan 69 has
sent a $2 stream labs contribution link
is in the video description
hey David would you ever go on the
discord and accept live questions from
viewers Town Hall stream when good
questions yeah I still don't know how to
get on the discord I'm kind of kidding I
mean I know how to get on it but I'm
never sort of I've never done it I guess
is what I'm trying to say I would be
willing to do that we would have to sort
of I guess coordinated and think about
when when that that would make sense but
yeah I think that that would be that
would be a really great thing to do I
would love to be on the discord let's go
back to super chats doobie dude has sent
a $50 super chat thank you instantly
putting him or horse or him or herself
at the top of the list for this evening
for super chats and stream lapse
contributions just wanted to let you
know the discord server dedicated to
your show is amazing you've got great
mods like snoop there that really do a
lot to create a positive atmosphere for
discussion have you dropped consider
dropping in to say hello we'll listen if
people are willing to spend $50 to tell
me that I should be on the discord then
I think I need to check out the discord
right I don't it's hard to imagine
really having any excuses not to at this
point so yeah I'm gonna try to check
that out
Rashard Hill has sent a $5 super check
do you think North Korea is making
themselves into the victim lately yeah
that that's a that's a common thing I
mean that's not that's not new they are
both the aggressor but the perpetual
victim so I'm not yeah I think I think
you're absolutely right that that's
absolutely something that they are that
they are doing xx Jamaica has sent the
$5 super check you should consider going
on the PKA podcast that would be amazing
and have you have you've been on other
podcasts I've been on many other
podcasts what is the pKa
Podcast let's see what that is short for
painkiller already a weekly gaming gone
comedy podcast I've never heard of it
but I would consider it let's see what
their YouTube channel looks like the PKA
podcast okay so it's like a group group
podcast type of thing yeah I would love
to be on if they invite me if they
invite me so if you have any connections
by all means tell them to get in touch
and it would be my utmost pleasure to
participate there okay let me do a few
thank-yous before we get too much
further in so number one membership is
the number one funding source for the
David Pakman show and you can sign up
for membership at david pakman.com slash
membership and I do have a few new
members to thank I want to send a big
thanks to Frank and Marie as well as
gage Bennett and Tim Rasmussen a lot of
rasmussen stuff going on a contribution
from Bryan Rasmussen and then we've got
Tim Rasmussen a lot of Rasmussen action
tonight and also Maura Freeman Maura
Freeman thank you so much for signing up
at david pakman.com slash membership and
no new patrons no new patrons it really
bums me out when we don't do well with
the patreon contributions we started the
evening at 1936 patrons I issued what is
really a very reasonable challenge of
1950 patrons if we get to 1950 it will
trigger a live stream only discount code
for membership and we've made no
progress to that whatsoever and you'll
notice that when I talk about patreon I
only talk about number of patrons I
don't care how much you contribute it's
really just about getting the largest
number of contributors possible really
that that's the way I see sort of the
best way to build community which is
engage the highest number of
contributors so even if it's just a
dollar I encourage you to do it we we
are looking at 2,000 patrons you'll see
at the bottom left of this screen shot
that our immediate goal is 2,000 patrons
when we
that I've agreed to do a full broadcast
program from David David Pakman show
studios with my hair like this and I
know it might not be a good idea it
might scare people it might involve the
FCC over indecent imagery but I've
committed to doing a full show with my
hair uncontrolled if we can get to 2,000
patrons and I think what I need to do is
I think the 2,500 patron mark needs to
be what would trigger me doing my Boston
College lectures on YouTube that is
something a lot of people have expressed
interest in I'm for people who don't
know I'm teaching as an adjunct
professor at the tremendous educational
institution of Boston College in the
Boston area and the class has a lot of
material on epistemology and critical
thinking critical media analysis and a
lot of other really valuable material
and I've sort of floated the idea of
doing those lectures in some way shape
or form on the YouTube channel now one
option would be just filming the
in-class lectures but there's a lot of
stuff related to grades and projects and
quizzes and all this stuff that I think
might be a distraction so my new idea
would be to actually create recreate
those lectures eliminating all the stuff
that's specific to the sort of class
material or class projects etc for
YouTube but it's a really quite a big
project because I would want to edit in
the slides that I use and videos
graphics all this different stuff so I
think maybe a good patreon target would
be when we get to 2500 patrons I will do
I will start doing the lectures I will
start the lectures on YouTube and I
think people would like them I mean
there's it's it's pretty good stuff so
anyway what I'm trying to say is let's
have a successful patreon mini fund
drive tonight let's just get 14 patrons
it'll get us the 1950 we will all cheer
we'll celebrate the cup will runneth
over as we might say and then we can
move on all right let me get into some
of the other comments and questions that
are being asked here and I do have by
the way if you have not
yet actually is it out yet I don't know
if it is so yesterday and today on the
broadcast show we had parts the first
and last part the first and second parts
I guess I would say of my interview with
Elizabeth Kolbert and I want to check
out here has that interview gone live it
hasn't okay so in a couple of days my
full conversation with Elizabeth Kolbert
is going to be live up on YouTube
members would already have been able to
see it you can sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership she wrote
the book the sixth extinction which was
highly recommended by President Obama
about the sixth extinction which we may
now be in on planet earth and it's
really really good and the interview was
absolutely fantastic so if you've if
you're not a member that will be popping
up on YouTube in a couple of days
otherwise it is already available to you
okay okay I've got a new stream labs
donation and question stream labs.com
slash the david pakman show this one is
from lizard-breath
who has sent a nine dollar contribution
can you please have a scientific look at
the effects from so much deforestation
and use of fossil fuel generators on the
islands affected by hurricanes it
astounds me that we don't send
solar-powered help to an area that is so
sunny yeah I mean you know we're so
backwards on solar power and and we know
that there's plenty of sunlight to
harness into solar power we know about
the drastically increased efficiency of
solar panels and deforestation we
actually did talk a little bit about
deforestation I don't know if you saw
lizard my email with interview with Ken
caldera earlier this week he's an expert
on ocean acidification and deforestation
is sort of something that might might be
in his wheelhouse he did send me an
email about some other ideas things we
could maybe do another interview
but yeah I need to talk more about
deforestation and really an interview on
deforestation I think would be would be
appropriate I think that that we
absolutely need it okay let's see
there was another there's a $5
contribution that came in but I'm still
not seeing the question for one reason
or another from CW hambone oh here it is
David Trump sometimes retweets comments
from his supporters do you think he ever
sees the negative comments that so many
people tweet to him or do you think he's
only ever exposed to what is in his
twice daily daily autofellatio folder
yes so what hambone is referring to is
that two times a day I think it's like
at 9:30 and 4:00 or something like that
there's basically like a mini an
internal propaganda team at the White
House and what they do is they compile
on paper positive stuff for Donald Trump
to look at and it's amazing because they
print out screen so if you watch a cable
news channel at the bottom there will
off often be what's called a lower third
right and it has some kind of message on
it and if it's a positive message about
Trump
they will screenshot and print out for
Trump screenshots of cable news which is
incredible
also positive tweets will sometimes be
printed out and handed and
hand-delivered to Donald Trump as part
of this propaganda folder for someone
who's against safe spaces and trigger
warnings and likes telling it like it is
it's amazing how sheltered and and he
sort of kept in a de facto safe space
rallies just with people who have been
hand-picked and are supportive thanks
Jamal I'll get to your question
momentarily it's it's just amazing and
that that I think I don't know that
Trump is really aware of all the
negative tweets that are constantly out
there about him I think he's pretty
deliberately kept kept in the dark about
that okay the next question is from
Jamal Swift with a $10 super Chatwood
Boston College and their students be
pissed that you were giving away
curricula
for free now I don't think so most
educational institutions are all about
publicizing the lectures and the classes
that are available Harvard and MIT have
tons of free classes available online
and and in the end it's not the exact
same material right and the truth is
that I speak about critical thinking and
media literacy all the time so no I
don't think anybody Jamaal fortunately
would be upset if I start doing
Boston College material on the YouTube
channel or via live streams or really
via anything else
Yesenia Moreno has sent a dollar super
chat who is your favorite
I'm sorry not super chat stream Labs
contribution who is your favorite
congressman and why exclude Bernie and
Warren well Bernie and Elizabeth Warren
are senators so I guess if we mean any
member of Congress when I hear Congress
I think House of Representatives I don't
have one you know and I know that that's
a lame answer but I just I see you know
99% of politicians as just generic
politicians and I just don't don't the
the concept to me of having a favorite
member of Congress I just I can't it
sounds even weird to for me to think
that way so I don't I'm sorry I don't
have a better answer for you Yesenia
because I can assure you if I had a
better answer for you I would absolutely
absolutely have given it to you okay
let me do a couple of other thank-yous
before we get to Dylan kaulitz question
couple more new members I want to thank
Gina Chase who has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership
thank you very much Gina I appreciate
that also Anthony Tippin Anthony Tippin
is a new member at david pakman.com
slash membership and shaun gordon shaun
gordon also signing up for a new
membership what is membership why do we
care about membership well most
importantly membership is the number one
funding source for the show but there's
great member benefits we do a daily
bonus show producer Pat and I and it's
just for our paid subscribers and you
can get access to that bonus show either
through membership or at the $5 a month
tribution level on patreon you also get
the entire show commercial free hours
after it is recorded so an example is
the Elizabeth Kolbert to interview the
Elizabeth Kolbert interview great
interview by the way great great
interview that was part of yesterday in
today's program right so if you are a
member or a patron at the predetermined
level for getting access to what we call
the full show by around 4:15 or 4:30
p.m. Eastern Time you've got a one-hour
video in the member portal of our
website and you can watch the entire
show you don't have to wait for clips to
publish every 90 minutes you don't have
to wait as you sometimes might have to
two days for the Elizabeth Kolbert
interview to go live publicly on YouTube
you get it all same day that I think
that that and the bonus show are really
the the core membership features that
people seem to like so thanks to people
who have signed up and you know what I'm
really kind of getting bummed out we
just nothing nothing's happening on
patreon we've had live streams where 30
even 40 new patrons will come on they
want to hear their name said they want
to hear their praises sang by me sung
sorry
English is my second language give me a
break and our target today was just 14
patrons I wanted to go from 1936 to 1950
a modest goal really particularly when
we've got any number of dollar
contributions coming in via super
chatted stream labs I would make a plea
to you if you've made contributions be a
super chat or stream laps or are
considering making them today consider
throwing in a dollar a month via patreon
because we keep a lot more of that money
than we do from super chats and it
really creates this community where when
people visit the patreon website the
higher the number of donors they see the
the more likely presumably it is that
they might be willing to contribute
because they'll get the impression and
correctly so that hey something's going
on here this is where to contribute
- so let's see if we can get to 1950 I
still am optimistic and sort of hoping
that we might be able to do that
Dylan Collett Dylan Collett sent a $2.00
super check any favorite musicians in
the Boston music scene I couldn't tell
you of a single one sadly I I go to like
no local music the last shows I've been
to in the Boston area have been sort of
in reverse order Billy Joel a few weeks
ago fantastic
I went to 311 and Matisyahu opening for
311 some of you know I'm friends with
modest bassists - Brooks
so whenever they're in town I'll check
out a show and they're actually coming
into town in the next few months again
and I'm looking forward to seeing them
they opened for 311 311 a band I grew up
with really enjoyed seeing them and
before that I think the last show that I
went to was an argentinian reggae band
called las penitas which I could not
more highly recommend to you they're
fantastic look him up check him out on
Spotify they had a they had one singer
for a long time who left the band some
years ago and their guitarist one of
their guitarists took over the singing
and I know that this is sort of you're
not supposed to say this and in the
universe of Los Padilla's kind of like
the new singer better I don't know maybe
it's just because I'm more familiar with
them okay let me switch from super chat
over to stream labs stream labs comm
slash the david pakman show Bryan
Rasmussen scenting $1 super chat who is
your current political hero and who
would you like to see run in 2020 I I'm
so terrible at these questions because I
just have such a hard time seeing
elected officials as heroes as far as
the 20/20 thing I've said it before and
you know Brian I love you but I've got
to say I need to stick to my guns on
this for lack of a better term although
I don't own any guns I think it's too
early to talk about 2020 I just think at
this point you know I did the camel I
Harris story because I was worried about
Democrat
the owners already sort of anointing
camel Harris for 20/20 but beyond that I
think the focus has to be on 2018 there
are actually there's an Alabama special
election coming up in December there's
an opportunity to defeat Roy Moore I
forget the guys name the Democratic
challenger in Alabama but he's a great
guy with great politics and he could
defeat Roy Moore that's that's this year
we've got to focus on 17 and 18 before
I'm gonna be ready to talk about 2020
and I hope you'll respect that Bryan
with all I say it with all due respect
and with peace and love okay
a user going by the name Spanish segment
has sent a $2.00 stream labs.com slash
the david pakman show contribution and
it is in Spanish and it's it's one of
these bizarre Spanish tongue twisters
and what I like to do is just read it as
written and usually it's written pretty
atrociously because we all know who it
is that's sending these hi Clark in any
case I will read it as written and I'll
try to do sort of a translation even
though usually they have they have no
meaning at all okay here it is un po dad
or po da ba la paura yo troppo dad or
que porra Shi pasaba la pregunta po dad
or que puedas la para que para polis po
das me para tu padre polis nee polo -
para mí para podo
que puedo la parada meteo Bartolo okay
not even gonna not even gonna dig into
that I mean we are talking about Trump's
Twitter account makes more sense right
Trump's Twitter account makes more sense
than that but I do appreciate I do
appreciate the $2 contribution there
yeah
Kristina thank you for your dollar
stream labs.com slash the david pakman
show contribution who would you consider
a hero if anyone I'm seeing a trend here
people really want me to list some idols
right so we had a convert we've Yesenia
asked about my favorite congressman and
then Brian asked about my current
political hero and Cristina's asking who
would I consider a hero
if anyone you know I
the people I consider heroes are the
people who sort of figure out a place
what I really envy and think is great is
figure people who figure out a place
that they can contribute to society in a
way that really is is bettering the
lives of others and it could be in any
way right it could be somebody working
in the medical field
it could be somebody who's teaching it
could be somebody through media or
whatever I I think that anybody who can
really have an impact on people and sort
of spread whatever it is that they have
to bring to the world I think that
that's heroic and you know it's very
easy to say well I say first responders
are the heroes or members of the
military are are the heroes and there
are endless praises to sing about all of
those individuals but for me it's a
little broader you know I know that that
maybe it's a little lame but that's sort
of the way I see it we are now getting
some patreon momentum okay now we are
talking Jessi Novello has pledged $2 a
month
Loker has pledged $2 a month
Dylan collet has made a pledge at
patreon.com slash David Pakman show of
$2 a month
and Elizabeth bond her bone has made a
$2 a month pledge that gets us now to
1941 patrons the target for tonight is
1950 we have failed time and again to
reach what I consider to be truly modest
goals for an evenings patreon
contributions and I forgot to thank
James Emmet who has also pledged $2 a
month
let's do it let's get to 1950 and when
we do I will trigger a 55% membership
discount code for you I think people
will really really like that but let's
just do it right let's let's let's
succeed here and if you see people
throwing us you know a dollar or two or
more as we see up here all we're talking
about is $1 right just a dollar a month
most people in the audience can't afford
that if you can't then by all means I'm
not asking for you to contribute a penny
because I really do the show for
everybody regardless of whether you can
contribute but only one to one and a
half percent of our audience contributes
financially and I'm just saying if we
could increase that to three percent
that would be pretty good that would
really make a pretty pretty significant
difference I would say Lord Reginald
Peterson has sent a 2 dollar super chat
with a very interesting question what
opinions have you recently reconsidered
uh that's what what positions have I
recently reconsidered
you know nothing major recently I think
that a better a better example of
positions I've reconsidered are really
there's two big ones ok when I was
younger I sort of fell for trickle-down
economics and really fell for a
traditional sort of classical down the
middle economics philosophy I guess you
would call it Keynesian economics and I
was sort of even influenced by like the
Chicago school like Milton Friedman and
eventually I got myself out of that and
I totally reconsidered my economic views
once I read more alternative economic
theory but it's not that like everybody
can say I read Marx and it changed my
life that's not what I'm saying
but once I actually took economics out
of the academic vacuum of perfectly
rational actors and all of that stuff
that economics likes to teach and sort
of experienced economics more in the
real world so I've made significant
changes on economic policy over many
years and actually I've really changed
my views on on transgenderism there was
a time where I've always been hugely
supportive of
gay lesbian bisexual rights and I did
have a phase where I knew less about
transgenderism where I probably held
some views that were less than totally
enlightened on the matter so I think
that that's another issue you know to
pick like a fiscal issue and a social or
cultural issue that that I've
reconsidered Hobbiton has sent a to
British pound super chat quit being cute
name a single person as your hero my my
maternal grandmother my maternal
grandmother was a hero of mine there's a
specific one the d2j bug has sent a five
Canadian dollar super chat we don't need
another hero we don't need to know the
way home all we want is life beyond the
Thunderdome really could not say it
better myself
a political monkey has sent the $2 super
chat how can we make the political
climate go our way well do you have a
few hours because I don't not today
anyway I mean I think you know at the
top level I've said this before and I'll
say it again whatever is your political
issue if it's education or women's
rights or LGBT rights or the climate
whatever your work within that issue
trying to move the needle in the
direction you see as best is really
going to be influenced by media and by
money in politics and really it's one in
the same right because a lot of the
money in politics ultimately is splint
spent on media influence campaigns so I
think that at the top level the best
thing we can do is work on the issue of
money and politics and how campaigns are
financed and also you know the system of
elections that we have in terms of and
I'm talking about everything from
members of Congress basically always
running for re-election because they
serve two-year terms the broader concept
of the two-party system I think we need
Instant Runoff voting I think that
that's a major thing I've spoken about
that it's really systemic stuff I mean
you asked a very general question and I
think that the answer has to start at
the general
that that really is where a lot of these
systemic issues are dictated okay
BW 85 has sent the $10 stream lapse
contribution the Donald said yesterday
he thinks they will have the necessary
votes to pass a health care bill in
January or February do you think he
fails to understand they'll need 60
votes at that point does the Republican
Party have any chance of actually
passing a health care bill so a few
different things in there I don't know
what Trump knows about how many votes he
needs
I really don't it's it's it's impossible
to know guys a [ __ ] right I mean you
know so little I don't think he knew
Puerto Ricans were American citizens
until a few days ago and someone
explained this is why so many people are
asking what the hell is going on with
Puerto Rican Aid so he says they'll have
the votes in January or February
February not even worth speculating
right now about that the broader
question does the Republican Party have
a chance of passing a health care bill I
think that the health care bill the
Republican Party could pass is going to
need to keep the affordable care act or
replace it with something that actually
has really a lot of those provisions
because we still talk about Obama care
as if like here's here's health care and
there's this like appendage stuck to it
that's Obamacare and we could remove
that at any time kind of like having a
wart removed or something like that but
it's been around for seven years right
and if you're 33 or younger
that means you were 26 when Obamacare
went went into became law which means
the entire time you've been out of your
parent's insurance depending on what
state you're in right Massachusetts we
had 26 on your parent's insurance before
Obamacare some states didn't but the
point is a vast majority of people who
are 30 between 31 and 33 today they have
only been sort of out on their own with
health care under Obamacare in another
year that's going to be 32 to 34 you're
not going to be able to just Lance
Obamacare like this separate entity with
every passing day that becomes more
difficult so I think that's the sort of
uphill battle that Republicans are
facing when it comes to the
CAIR repealed christina has sent a
dollar stream live super chat i like
your definition but i would also add to
the list of heroes david pakman show
patreon members from what i hear they
are all great people who could possibly
deny that who could possibly deny that
and on that note i have a couple new
patrons to thank negan's cat has pledged
$1 a month and chris walker has made a
pledge of $1 a month you know what we
might for the first time in weeks or
even longer hit the patreon contributors
goal the contributor goal was 1954 this
evening and we're at nineteen forty
three we are just seven new patrons away
from nineteen fifty why do we care about
getting to nine nineteen hundred and
fifty patrons because if we do I will
create a clever membership discount code
I will announce it only on the stream
and you find people will have the
opportunity to sign up for memberships
at a fifty five percent discount okay we
just need seven more contributions and
they can be for as little as a dollar a
month let's do it let's just make it
happen let's get it over with okay
the super chats and stream labs
questions keep coming in Bryan Rasmussen
is up next with a five dollar super
chapter would you consider doing an
in-depth video on the loss of purchasing
power of the middle class yeah I think
that's interesting I mean basically
you've had stagnant wages for 40 years
in inflation-adjusted dollars and we've
had inflation we've had inflation so I I
think that that's an interesting topic
and I will make a note of it now and I
think that would be a good one we've got
a dozen or more good topics on on our
list of long-form pieces okay let's go
over and I'll sort of alternate we'll go
back over to stream labs.com slash the
david pakman show CW hambone has sent a
$2.00 contribution asking david if you
were dating a girl and after developing
strong feelings for her found out she
was transgender
would it be a deal-breaker for you does
post versus pre-operation make a
difference
yeah I've addressed this before on the
show you know my my belief is that I
would not be interested in being with
someone who was born a man that's my
that's my feeling right now
now you could react and say you know
David that's some kind of discrimination
or transphobia maybe maybe I'm wrong
right but my instinct is that first of
all I think it would be difficult to be
in a situation where such strong
feelings have developed and it's it's
not been I'm sort of picking my words
carefully it's not been discussed or
made evident that the person may not
have been born a woman I mean certainly
post versus pre-operation I think would
make a difference I just I just can't
imagine any circumstances where I would
I would be in a relationship with
someone who shares the the same
genitalia I have and I that that's my
view and you know this is just kind of
how I feel now maybe maybe things will
change at some point I don't know okay
let's now switch back over to super chat
xx Jamaica or no let's see yes xx
Jamaica sent a $5 contribution do trans
have a mental disorder I am NOT educated
this if you can please explain well I'm
not a doctor but from everything I know
transgenderism is not a mental disorder
but I'm not a doctor I just go by what I
read xx Jamaica with another $2 super
chat what shows do you watch I mean
right now I'm really only watching one
show which is the sort of Colombian
original version of narcos narcosis on
Netflix and it's like a half Spanish
half English story of Pablo Escobar the
Colombian drug lord I'm watching the
original Colombian version it's called
el patron the mod and it's all in
Spanish sub billed in English I find it
much
entertaining and grossing and really
really liked it so that's what I'm
watching now I recently finished
watching Ozark which is a Netflix
original really really good with Jason
Bateman like that one I'm waiting for
the next season of mr. robot I'm waiting
for the next season of better call Saul
and what else and the Americans which is
ending I like the Americans I think
that's also a good show that doesn't get
enough credit doesn't get enough credit
okay we continue to inch closer to 1950
patrons we started the evening at 1936
with the very generous and much
appreciated contribution of Geoffrey
Burnett of $2 per month we have now
gotten one contribution closer to 1950
and that places us showed us at 1942 but
I'm seeing 1944 so I'm wondering if
there are a couple no I'm sorry that's
the right number 1944 we are six
contributions away only six more
contributions on patreon and I will have
no choice but to keep to my word and
create and release a 55% membership
discount code for you let's make it
happen let's make it happen we got 10 15
minutes left here okay a number of other
questions coming in here Paul Thompson
sent a $2 super check what are your
thoughts on the rise of DSA I don't know
what DSA is that that could mean any
number of things
Oh Democratic socialists of America yeah
I think it's interesting you know I
don't consider myself a socialist I am a
supporter of social democracy which is
well regulated capitalism that
appropriately funds social welfare
programs that really we all have a
shared interest in making sure our as
strong as possible but there's no doubt
that the term socialist is less of a
dirty word than it's been for a very
very long time and I'm super interested
in following where this goes and and
seeing sort of what you know the the
real question is what impact on
mainstream politics will people's
openness to socialism or socialistic
policies have because that's really you
know if DSA gets more
members but it has no impact on modern
American politics then we could argue
it's not really doing that much but I'm
confident that there will be
trickle-down impact Jayne womanpower has
sent a five Canadian dollar super chat
can't wait Trump and his family if
crooks are gone the world will be great
again how the universe will be great
again couldn't really add to that Jane
thank you appreciate the contribution
political monkey can we get to the Trump
Russia stuff no no no political among or
maybe if you go by monkey we got to it
at the beginning we got to it at the
beginning of the stream had a long
conversation about it so I would
encourage you to scroll back scroll back
now I am trying to get to people's
questions
Jane woman tower also topping off her
contributions with another two Canadian
dollar super chat thanks so much Jane I
really do appreciate that at stream
labs.com slash the david pakman show
people are also able to make
contributions red Rodina redmond has
sent a $10 contribution saying greeting
via the black ssin facebook group we
still have your back alright
i don't know what that is I hope I hope
that's not that's not one of the
Facebook groups that we found was an
infiltrated group as I mentioned at the
top of the of the livestream no reason
to think that it is but that happened a
little too closely to me talking about
that so it's a little bit scary but
thank you I really do appreciate that
do be dude has sent a $5 super chat
doobie dude says just for your
information that coin animation is
driving the group in the TPS discord
server which you should totally visit
insane but it's okay we still love you
what's bad about it I it's over here it
is yeah it's it's my beer glass well is
it driving people crazy because it's
annoying or because people like it and
if it's because people don't like it
somebody please send another super chat
and explain why people on the discord
don't like this thing I think it's
pretty cool
but we can also remove it next time if
people really don't like it
Justin Sanchez has sent a $2 super chat
Santiago says in the chat will Trump
attack Venezuela I believe that he will
not and that is maybe partially cautious
optimism I I want to believe that Donald
Trump will not attack Venezuela
but you know who really knows at this
point how many different countries can
we prevent Donald Trump from attacking
that's increasingly a relevant question
at this point but I hope he doesn't
attack Venezuela and not because I'm a
supporter of the Maduro regime
I've been abundantly clear abundantly
clear that I am NOT a supporter of
Nicolas Maduro and was also not a
supporter of Hugo Chavez okay so I guess
people aren't liking the coin animation
on the discord where is it it's over
here yeah here it is
because the coins miss and some of the
coins fall out of the glass okay well
listen these are these are first world
problems for sure right I mean the
animation on this okay I don't think I
have to say any more about that we are
starting to run out of time though if we
are going to hit our target of nineteen
hundred and fifty patrons we do have to
do it pretty soon we've got about five
or ten minutes left now I would love to
get to 1950 so that then I can go in and
create a funny coupon code which I will
only tell you about and that will get
you a fifty five percent discount off of
memberships however it's kind of slowing
down a little bit we still need six more
patrons in order to get to nineteen
fifty and it only needs to be a dollar a
month and and we will get there we
started at nineteen thirty-six eight new
patrons throughout the stream and now
we're just six away but time is quickly
vanishing we are running out of time
time we cannot get back so if there's an
interest if there's an interest in a 55
percent membership discount code so that
we can all cheer a successful live
stream telethon
let's get those contributions in because
I would I would we just haven't I've
been doing pretty modest challenges on
that and we've just not been we've just
not been doing well we've not been doing
well with it and that's sad it's very
very sad to me okay a couple other
things upcoming on the program let me
tell you what's coming up on the show I
mentioned that we have this great
interview with Elizabeth Elizabeth
Kolbert which is going live on the
YouTube channel Saturday already
available for our paid subscribers next
week we've got a bunch of great stuff
going on on Monday we're going to have
arguably the most frequent guest from
David Pakman show history not Shirley
phelps-roper from the Westboro Baptist
Church I'm talking about Bill share bill
share friend of the show fellow well not
fellow I mean I guess I don't live there
now but fellow a knit former neighbor
from Northampton Massachusetts bill
scher put out a very controversial
article where he says you know Democrats
should actually stop talking about
Medicare for all it's just whatever you
think about Medicare for all in terms of
its merits it's not good strategy for
Democrats to talk about in support
Medicare for all I don't agree with him
so we're going to talk to him on Monday
on Tuesday I will be interviewing Boston
University's Sandro Galia about the ways
in which natural disasters connect with
public health and the public health
issues and considerations that will be a
really good interview and then I think
people are really going to like this
Wednesday I will be interviewing Gerald
Friedman
Gerald Friedman is an economist and
professor of economics at my alma mater
graduate alma mater the University of
Massachusetts for years he has been
putting forth proposals for how he says
Medicare for all or some other
single-payer health care system would be
very affordable like he has the numbers
he actually has done the work which many
people say nobody has done so Gerald
Friedman or Jerry as he goes by will be
joining me on Wednesday and then at the
end of next week there next week there's
no Friday show the Thursday show will
have the format of the Friday show
because I'm going to be at a wedding in
Arizona in fact for Columbus Day weekend
and then the following week is is really
just as good we're going to be
interviewing an Obama former Obama
speech writer David litt who has great
great stories we are going to be we've
got an upcoming interview with mark
Ruskin who's a former undercover FBI
agent I'm reading his book now I tweeted
it yesterday and it's it's a fantastic
book I mean truly excellent excellent
book about his experience working
undercover at the FBI and he is actually
half Argentinian I found out through
reading the book so I think it's gonna
be it's gonna be interesting christina
has sent a dollar stream labs.com
slash the david pakman show contribution
the cup is cute christina likes the cup
that's over here where coins fall into
when you make contributions all right
Bryan
Rasmussen sent the dollar contribution I
watched your interview with Ben Shapiro
today about gun violence were you
annoyed as I was were you as annoyed as
I was that he was dodging your questions
you know it was a while ago that I did
that interview I don't remember the
degree to which he dodged my questions
so I guess I can't say for sure whether
I was annoyed at the time but if he was
dodging my questions I probably was
annoyed because that does tend to annoy
me
I would actually be interested in having
Ben Shapiro back again he is much more
well-known now than he was back when we
did that interview and I think that that
would be an interesting thing but we
would have people say debate Ben Shapiro
okay well on what topic it's not hey Ben
let's debate go we would have to think
about a topic and really think about one
that we both I think we should both be
passionate about it right like we can
come up with something to debate but
unless it's really an issue that is that
is of importance to both of us I don't
know that it it'll be that interesting
or that I see the value in doing it but
open invitation absolutely
okay a couple other super chats here
William Barton sent a $2 super chat with
no question or comment thanks very much
Jane womanpower has sent a five Canadian
dollar super chat did I miss you live
with your outrage
hairdo very important right up there
with Trump lol no you didn't so what
you're referring to is this right and
what I've said is that when we get to
2,000 patrons at patreon.com slash david
pakman show i will do an entire show
from the studio with my hair like this
we've not yet gotten to that we started
the evening at 1936 we are now at we're
getting pretty close libre libre de
goiânia has sent a dollar a month pledge
Brian Lindbergh has sent a $2 a month
ledge so that gets us our target is 1950
we're at 1946 but the point is when we
get to 2000 is when I'll do an entire
broadcast show with my hair like this
and we haven't we haven't gotten there
yet
I I do want to tell you I'm basically
ready to wrap for the night because it's
getting late because we are so close to
1950 patrons I'm gonna hang out five
more minutes because I really would like
to have a successful achievement of a
patreon target
we just need four more at this point
four more dollar a month contributors
and we will get to nineteen fifty and if
we do I will create a live stream only
membership discount code so let's do it
we're very very close just four more
contributions do be dude has sent a five
dollar super jet political degenerate
from the discord server you should
totally visit says he could absolutely
destroy you in a debate on any topic
just saying okay well I encourage
political degenerate then to start a
program and anyone with that degree of
confidence in debating politics in
debating people on any topic must
certainly have very very interesting
things to say and I would encourage them
to start a program that would be step
one to start getting their sort of
political ideas out there right why not
I think that that's a really really
great idea and I hope that the political
degenerate will do that we get caught
you know I here's what I would suggest
have political degenerate call in during
live calls and have have political
degenerate call the show we will be able
to pick up the call presumably we have a
lot of calls but hopefully we can get
two political degenerate and then call
me out on some you know point of view
some position that you disagree with and
we can we can have a mini debate or
something like that that's the
opportunity I can present you and you
know take it or leave it any ghost has
sent a twenty dollar stream Labs
contribution in Puerto Rico total
darkness except for the corporate strip
in sunk one six plus our weights for gas
self-service spotty I have to park my
car I have to park in my car near the
Convention Center for four G please
don't let this get cycled out of the new
cycle understood any ghosts understood
and I am going to do everything I can to
keep the Puerto Rico story in the news
to the extent that I am able right and
my power is not unlimited but I will do
absolutely everything I can to try to
keep that going because it is absolutely
horrible what is going on
and you know the I saw an interview
today with someone
some FEMA higher up or I don't know
executive I don't even know what to call
them on CN n around 11:00 a.m. Eastern
and guy seemed beaten down I mean just
irritable he did seem kind of
argumentative but who can blame him
right I mean it's it's just it's not
going well it is not going well at all
and I just what can you do what can you
say so yeah thank you any ghosts
appreciate that thank you for the
contribution and stay safe in Puerto
Rico when when there's no power and
limited water and limited supplies
things can get dicey or complex we know
that but yeah thank you so much for the
contribution and on that note I'm going
to wrap up I've stayed an extra few
minutes here trying to get to
50 patrons but sadly it hasn't happened
we started the evening at 1936 the
target was 1950 we got to 1946 just four
shorts we will try again we will try
again that I promise you